I grew up in Providence, Rhode Island, and for my entire childhood, we were never more
than 20 miles away from the core of our universe, the Kennedys.
We were Irish, they were Irish.
We were Catholic, they were Catholic.
They were family.
We were like the relatives that they never got to see.
But we knew, you know, they're busy, and we knew that they loved us.
So anything that was happening to them was also happening to us.
So their tragedy, plus our own tragedy, was a lot.
So this one Thanksgiving after dinner and a family fight at Grandma's house, we were
in the car and we're driving home.
And the radio was playing this 10th anniversary of the JFK assassination.
And I'm sitting in the back seat, and I start to cry.
And my sister Erin says, hey, Dad, Michaela's crying.
And my father pulls that car right over to the shoulder of I-95.
He stops it, he turns around, and he looks at us.
And with tears in his own eyes, he says, don't you ever be ashamed to cry for that man.
So my parents grew up near Newport, and they got married in the same exact church as Jack
and Jackie, St. Mary's.
And my father gave exact replica jewelry to my mother that was replications of the jewelry
that Jack gave to Jackie.
And every Saturday night after mass, my family would be in the living room and we'd be happily
ever aftering to the original soundtrack of Camelot.
And every year during the 70s, my four aunts would take me and my two cousins on their
dream vacation, a rented beach house in Hyannis on the very cove sharing beachfront with the
Kennedy compound.
Every day for an entire week, my Aunt Pat would roll up her sister's hair.
My aunts would apply sunscreen to the back of their necks, the backs of the hands, and
the tops of their feet.
And then they would drag their beach chairs down to the beach, and they would set them
up perfectly, not facing the water, not into the sun for tanning, but perfectly for spying
on the Kennedys.
They would sit there all day in the broiling sun with high-powered binoculars and keep
a constant surveillance.
And every year they'd have the same exact conversations.
Usually around mid-morning, the first sighting would be made, usually by my Aunt Pat.
She'd be, up, they got Rose out, walking, Ethel looks drawn.
And then about an hour later, my Aunt Gert would say, how old is Rose now?
And Aunt Momo would make the calculations.
Well, let's see.
Jack died in 63 when she was 74, and Rose's birthday was two weeks last Thursday, and
Joe died in 69, making her a widow at 81, so 85.
And then they'd break for lunch.
So after lobster and drawn butter and hosing us down, they'd all hustle back to their posts,
and they'd watch.
And every now and then, there'd be something they didn't know.
Hey, who's that?
Who's that?
So they'd draw out the family tree in the sand, they'd analyze it, they'd come up with
a profile, and they'd crack the code.
It's one of Bobby's.
Now any mention of Bobby would always bring up the inevitable, oh, I just pray to God
they don't tell poor senile Rose about Bobby, it'll break her.
So then the long afternoon stretch would end with the inevitable annual observation, you
don't see Jackie much here.
And then all of my aunts would drop their binoculars and look at each other meaningfully.
Now all of this meant that no one was paying any attention to me and my cousins in the
water.
And the summer when we were nine years old, we found something.
Now had an aunt, perhaps in an effort to ease a cramp in her prying neck, just sort of glanced
towards the water.
She might have seen us climbing into this tiny plastic half inflated boat.
She might have cried out an alarm at the lack of oars and life vests.
She might have had a conniption fit to see us shove off and drift into the violent rip
tide that would sweep us within five minutes out to the open sea and the Nantucket bound
ferry.
But an aunt didn't, and we did.
It all happened so fast that we were swept out, and it wasn't until we realized that
we could make out the specific features of the ferry passengers that we were really
far from shore.
We were so far from shore that my aunts were now reduced to four hopping dots.
Uh oh, it was like Gilligan's Island for real.
So an Atlantic swell crashes over our heads, and as soon as the water clears out of our
eyes, a powerboat pulls up out of nowhere.
And in this powerboat are David and Michael Kennedy.
So David and Michael pull us up into the boat, and we are like, oh my God, we are saved by
a powerboat.
So the powerboat sends us back to shore, and we're psyched because we're saved until we
start to watch the four hopping dots morph back into our four crazed, livid aunts.
We are so going to get it.
Now my family under any circumstances has this really weird thing, well they each have
like their own weird thing, about like yelling and getting into huge trouble.
Like my aunt Gur, like she gets so freaked out that all she can do is yell out our addresses.
Like Eileen and Kevin, 275 Hooper Street.
Michaela, 180 Asylum Road.
I swear to God, I grew up on Asylum Road.
It's a very telling piece of my childhood.
And then my aunt Pat would do these things where she would say these things that were
like actually kind of nice things, but she'd say them like they were death threats.
She'd be like, yeah, I'll save you from drowning.
You get on that beach towel and you lie in that sun, now.
Or she'd say, I'm going to buy you a birthday present.
You eat that cake, now.
So we knew that this is what was coming.
The Kennedy boys didn't.
So they're vivaciously tanned and they pull up to the shoreline and we brace ourselves.
Now what happens is our aunts are out of their minds.
They're ready to flay us.
But when they see us in the same boat as the Kennedys, it's like they don't have the
emotional capacity to handle it.
They kind of snap.
They're kind of like freaking out to yell at us, but they start fake smiling and trying
to act all normal.
And my aunt Momo, she takes on this Kennedy-esque way of speaking, which is sort of halfway
between Katharine Hepburn and the Queen of England.
And we're looking at them like, what are you guys doing?
And they're smiling to smile, but when they smile at us, it's like, you just wait.
But they're like, oh, David, oh, Michael, thank you, thank you, thank you.
And they're not mad at us for almost drowning.
They're mad at us because the Kennedys had to save us.
Like don't those people have enough trouble?
Now you?
Like as if our almost drowning was yet another Kennedy tragedy.
So these poor boys finally pull and pry themselves away from my aunts.
They get back on the boat and they're leaving and my aunt Momo's going, please give our
best to your grandmother.
And now it's time for our for real punishment, which was that we for the rest of vacation
had to stay on the beach because we did not have any respect for the water.
So it's a hundred degrees out.
And after about a half hour of whining and fighting and like emptying out all the copper
tone and kicking sand, we break my aunt Pat's last nerve and she says, all right, you can
go in the water, but only up to your knees.
So we're happy for a minute until we get in the water and realize how boring up to
your knees is.
And then we get the great plan of having chicken fights.
So we start to have chicken fights, but it's kind of weird because there's only three of
us.
So, but we're doing the best we can to have a chicken fight like that and like knock each
other off into the water so we get fully immersed.
And then my uncle Al, who never ever played with us ever comes into the water to play
chicken fights with us and he puts his daughter, my cousin Eileen up on his shoulders.
And then I get up on my cousin Kevin's shoulders and we're having chicken fights and it's like
actual family fun for a moment.
And we're like, you know, hitting each other, falling in the water.
And then I take my foot and I accidentally kick the side of my uncle Al's head really,
really hard and his eyeball pops out of his head, falls into the water and sinks.
It pops out of his head and it sinks.
Eileen, Kevin and I are in instant complete shock.
Right this minute there is still a part of me that is on that beach screaming.
It's like, oh my God, we had no idea that he had a fake eye.
We didn't even know that you could have a fake eye.
Why would you have a fake eye?
They didn't tell us that you, that uncle Al had a fake eye because they didn't want his
blabbing it to the whole neighborhood.
So they didn't tell us.
So we didn't know.
And like later on, you know, there was Columbo and Sandy Duncan, but this was way before that.
We had no idea.
So we're all standing there and it's like so horrible.
Like I can't even like, I'm like, oh my God.
And, and my cousins Eileen and Kevin are staring at me with complete hate.
Like you broke our dad.
And my uncle Al is standing there and he's got the lid open so you can like see inside
the socket where now it's just like skin and the eyeball gone.
And like, you cannot just say I'm sorry to someone that you just, so I don't know what
to do.
And my aunt Pat is hysterically screaming because that eyeball cost top dollar.
It was a special magnetized eye so it could keep up with the other one.
And now I had just been to pray that vacation was over and that they got that deposit back
because now they were going to have to buy a brand new top dollar eye that was not in
the budget.
So I just didn't know what to do.
I was like, my life is over.
I am no longer Michaela.
I am now Murph's girl who kicked Al's eye out in the cape.
And it's awful and everybody's just crying and pointing at me and now my other aunts
are getting in on it like and who's the blame part of the conversations happening.
So I just kind of back off into the water.
I'm kind of like going back and like regressing back to like where life as I once knew it
had ended.
And I just stand there and like, I kind of wish I had drowned and I kind of wish
the Kennedys hadn't saved me.
And I bent off into the waves and I just, I just started like sifting through sand and
shells and pebbles and it's totally ridiculous but like I will never stop looking for this
eye.
I'm going to look forever.
And I keep looking and looking and I'm sifting through and then all of a sudden there is
an eyeball in my palm staring right at me.
And so I scream and I drop it back and it sinks back into the water.
But now we know it's possible.
So everybody gets back into the water and now we're all sifting through and sifting
through and I pray to God for no more future happiness until we find this eye.
And I also kind of pray that it not be me that finds it this time.
So after like an hour my cousin Kevin finds the eye and he holds it up in triumph and
he does not let go.
And my uncle Al takes the eye, he like washes it off and just pops it back in.
And then he kind of like tests it, you know, and it's like keeping up with the other one.
So it's working still.
And now it's the weirdest thing because now we know it's a fake eye.
And now that you know it's a fake eye, it totally looks like a fake eye.
And I can't believe that I never noticed it wasn't a fake eye before.
So now vacation's back on.
And so everybody gets back into their beach chairs and they start to settle down to begin
telling the story over and over like a million times about what I just did.
And I have not really fully reintegrated back into the family yet.
I'm kind of standing apart.
And I notice that there actually has been like kind of a group of people who've been
watching this whole thing.
And then I see something that I didn't notice that no one noticed.
And that's that two of the Kennedy kids, David and Michael, had taken a walk on the beach.
And I can tell just by the look on their faces that they had stood there and seen the entire
episode, that they had been there watching us.
Thank you.